nuevo episodio de tensión entre israel e
irán de la vip acusa a teherán del
ataque a un buque operado por la empresa
zodiac marítima propiedad de un
multimillonario israelí el pasado 30 de
julio cuando un supuesto dron suicida
impactó contra el petrolero mercer
street frente a las costas de omán y
causó la muerte de dos tripulantes un
rumano y un británico israel señaló
inmediatamente a irán como responsable
del ataque y este domingo el gobierno de
tel aviv aseguró tener pruebas de ello
sólo son iván así que lo digo de manera
inequívoca irán es quien llevó a cabo el
ataque al barco habitable también elevan
el matoneo de irán es peligroso no sólo
para israel sino también para los
intereses globales y esperamos que la
comunidad internacional de deje claro al
régimen iraní que ha cometido un grave
error nosotros en todo caso tenemos
nuestra propia manera de transmitir el
mensaje a irán
reino unidos se sumó a los señalamientos
contra teherán asegurando que es
altamente probable que irán estuviera
detrás del ataque creemos que este
ataque fue deliberado dirigido y una
clara violación del derecho
internacional por parte de irán sin
embargo irán rechaza
las acusaciones estas distracciones no
son nada nuevo lo vemos de vez en cuando
sobre todo cuando suceden cosas buenas
en la región lo he dicho una vez y lo
repetiré el régimen que ocupa los
territorios palestinos ha traído consigo
inseguridad violencia terror y guerra
dondequiera que vaya y por eso los
responsables son los que han traído este
régimen en la región desde hace años que
la vip y teherán se acusan mutuamente de
librar una guerra oculta ambos países se
señalan como responsables de incidentes
navales en las principales rutas
marítimas de oriente medio e irán
también culpa a israel de sabotajes en
sus plantas de enriquecimiento de uranio
las tensiones en la región del golfo se
han intensificado desde la reimposición
de sanciones a irán por parte de eeuu
que en 2018 se retiró del pacto nuclear
de 2015 el ministro de exteriores de
israel y air lápiz discutió con su
homólogo estadounidense anthony blinken
con miras a coordinar una respuesta
internacional a las presuntas agresiones
iraníes